اعلن البيت الابيض الافراج عن لاعبه السله
الامريكيه بريتني جراينر المحتجزه في
روسيا بصفقه تبادل سجناء مع موسكو شملت
رجل الاعمال الروسي فيكتور بوت واعتقلت
جريل الفائزه بميداليتين ذهبيتين
اولمبييتين في فبراير شباط الماضي في مطار
موسكو باستخدامها سجائر الكترونيه تحتوي
على زيت القنب المحظور في روسيا وحكمت
محكمه الروسيه في الرابع من اغسطس اب
الماضي على جراينر بالسجن تسع سنوات وكانت
بريتني في زياره الى روسيا للاعب مع احدى
الفرق الروسيه في فتره توقف الدوري
الامريكي لكره السله للسيده
وفي كلمه وجهها بالتزامني مع الاعلان عن
اطلاق سراح جراينر قال الرئيس الامريكي او
جوبادل ان ادارته عملت منذ فتره طويله من
اجل هذا اليوم
وتعاهد باعاده الامريكيه المعتقل في روسيا
فول ويلن الى الوطن
في روسيا دون سبب منذ سنوات اعاده
الامريكيين الى وطنهم امر واجب وليست امرا
اختياريا لقد عدنا الى الوطن
خلال هذا العام للاسف تتعامل روسيا مع
قضيه بولويلان بشكل المغاير عن قضيه
بريتني لن نتخلى عن محاولاتنا وسنبقى على
تواصل مستمر مع عائله بول وسن واصل
التفاوض بحسن نيه من اجل اطلاق الصراحه
اضمن لكم ذلك
بدوره اساء دا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
بجهود الاجهزه الحكوميه التي بذلت لاطلاق
سراح بريتني جراينر ودور المبعوث الرئاسي
الخاص لشؤون الرهائن روجر كاستنز واشار
لينكن الى تواصل الجهود لاعاده الامريكي
بول ويلن المحتجز في روسيا مضيفا ان
الحكومه الروسيه لا تزال غير مستعده
لاطلاق سراحه من جانبه قال مسؤول في البيت
الابيض ان نتبادل السجناء استثناء ومن
الخطا ان يتم الاستنتاج بانه سيكون
القاعده
للمزيد تنضم الينا من البيت الابيض مراسله
الجزيره وجد وقفي اهلا بك وجد اذا ملف
يغلق في مساله السجناء الامريكيين هل
اتضحت الصوره بشكل
ما عن وضع
المحتجزه الاخر ويلن لماذا لم يتم اطلاق
سراح وماذا قالت عائله بريتني حتى الان
هم ينتظرون وصولها بفارغ الصبر طائرتها اا
هي اقلعت وهي على وشك ان تحط في الولايات
المتحده
لتنضم الى عائلتها فيما يتعلق
بباولن يعني حتى الان الرئيس بيدن اكد بان
جهود اعادته الى الولايات المتحده واطلاق
سراحي ما زالت مستمره وكما ذكر وزير
خارجيه بل يمكن فان همم موسكو غير مستعده
حتى الان اطلاقيه ويلا عن المعتقل منذ عام
بتهمه التجسس وحكم عليه بالسجن همم 16
عاما لهذه التهمه هو همم عنصر سابق في
المارينز وهو حاليا او قبل لحظه اعتقاله
كان يعمل رجل اعمال وكان بهذه الصفه وبصفه
مواطن امريكي في زياره الى روسيا عام 2018
عندما تم اعتقاله فيما همم بردود الفعل
حقيقه عبد السلام الجمهوريون رحبوا باطلاق
سراح بريتنينج واينر ولكن اكدوا بانه كان
ينبغي ايضا اطلاق صراحه همم بول همم
هناك مفاوضات حفيفه بحسب البيت الابيض منذ
الصيف الماضي وتحديدا في يوليو كانت هذه
المباحثات قد بدات وكان هناك شبه اتفاق
على اطلاق سراحها انا ذاك ولكن ما نعلمه
بان هذه الجهود توقفت ثم اعيد احيائها
بهذا الشتاء بان نجم عن ذلك عن هذه الجهود
اطلاق سراح همم
بريتنير طبعا بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
هناك تاكيدات كما ذكر مسؤول رفيع بان همم
تبادل السجناء هو ليس ان نهج المعتمد لدى
الاداره الامريكيه مثل هذه الصفقات ولكن
هذه حالات نادره وقد تم بالفعل اطلاق سراح
بريتني بناء على هذا المبدا شكرا